(staccato string music)
- [Narrator] Vietnamese food
is bountiful in Portland.
From Pho to Bành Mì, it's hard to miss.
But among your classic
Vietnamese restaurants,
there is one tiny place
that makes soups from
different regions of Vietnam
that you can't find anywhere
else outside the country.
How that place came to be involves the CIA
and is one hell of a journey.
(staccato string music)
(light chamber music)
(keys rattling)
(light piano music)
(cameral clicks)
- [Narrator] By the
time the U.S. pulled out
of the Vietnam War in 1973,
William was put in jail
by the Communist regime.
He would spend the next 10
years of his life in prison.
(camera clicks)
- [Narrator] After being released,
it took William six years
to reunite with his family
(camera clicks)
who settled in Portland.
Away from his homeland
and missing the comforts
of home cooking, he had an idea.
- [Narrator] Six days a week,
William and his wife, Christina,
come in and make two
distinct soups from scratch,
each soup representing a
different part of Vietnam.
That's it, a two-item
menu that changes daily.
And by early afternoon, they sell out.
(knife chopping methodically)
- [Narrator] 5:00 a.m.
wake-up, six days a week,
complex broths from scratch,
people half their age
wouldn't be able to last long.
So how are they still going?
(William laughs)
(staccato string music)
(octave bell tone)